hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts use of protein
expression system for influenza mucosal
the vaccine research presented by dr.
Haruki Hasegawa director of the
Department of Pathology at National
Institute of infectious diseases live
from Tokyo Japan I'm Suzy Valdez and I
will be your moderator for this
educational webcast
presented by lab routes and sponsored by
tiptoe part of thermo Fisher Scientific
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located at the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time at the end of
the presentation also please notice that
you will be viewing the presentation in
the slide window to enlarge that window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right if you have trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
please click on a support button at the
top right of the presentation window or
the Q&A button to let us know that
you're having a problem please join me
now in welcoming dr. Hideki Hasegawa I
never will now turn the presentation
over to him welcome sir thank you very
much hello everybody this is he taking
us together from Tokyo Japan
today I'm going to present about the use
of written expression system for our new
friends and the cause of vaccine
research we are developing the more
effective vaccine which is the mucosal
vaccine administered internally and the
the background of the development of
this vaccine is followed and listed as
follows now there are there is current
problems of the associated with the
design of the flu vaccine it is
difficult to predict the influenza virus
strain that will cause the next epidemic
or pandemic and the test various
fashions or tested
for the induction of the cross
protections and Sabbath Kenya's
vaccination is not very effective if
antigenicity of the vaccine strain is
different from the field strain select a
nice flu vaccine reduce the severity of
the disease but doesn't prevent the
infection itself to solve these problems
a new effective vaccination method is
necessary that can induce mucosal
immunity safely and that can protect
from variant viruses this is a figure
with mucosal surfaces which is a
frontline over the battle between the
virus and there our host immune systems
and beyond the infection of the virus to
the mucosal cells there is a maze to
major intelligence causes occurred one
is the induction of the IgG antibodies
in the in the serum and the other is the
IgA antibodies which is actively
secreted on the surface of the mucosa
the we can prepare these the secreted
antibodies before the virus arrived to
the observe cells we can prevent the
infection itself so on this research we
take advantage of the protein
experiences protein expression system to
produce the hemorrhaging molecule of the
influenza viruses because there is the
many strains and the subtypes of the in
event of viruses so we need the specific
antigens to detect the specific
antibodies in the samples so we produce
the each hemagglutinin molecule by the
expression system using the XP to 9f
cells that with this system we already
prepared more than ten
hemagglutinin
Michael which is a trimeric form of the
immigration in as nature form and the we
can obtain the Milgram order of the each
emigrating in the two hundred milliliter
cultures and I would like to show you
the example of our result of our
experiments the the application of the H
G protein expressed by the X P 2 9 3 F
Selleck sir system is used for as
Latinas analyzed antigen to detect the
specific IgG antibody and IgE antibodies
in the samples and number to use the
protein as an experiment vaccine
antigens ok this is a schedule and a
designer schedule of our human
experiments using the inactivated for
very young facts in for the seasonal
influenza virus a three and to the fifty
healthy frontiers internationally
administered the four variant vaccine
twice with the three weeks intervals and
three weeks after the second vaccination
the sufferers of the theorem and another
was was collected this is the result of
the hemagglutination inhibition titers
in the theorem in the left panel and
another was in the on the right panel as
you see here that after the second
vaccination the American invasion title
in the serum increased from the sixteen
point two to sixty eight point eight and
the South Terrace vaccination in this
only the serum antibodies but now the
administration of the vaccine
induce the origination inhibition titled
antibody in the nozzle washes as you see
here GMT which is limited is three
thirty eight point eight after the
second vaccination here is a summary of
the antibody responses in the
serum the main geometric increase and
the conversion rate and the protein rate
is meet to the criteria for the serum ID
h CI antibody in European medical agency
listed in the table and in addition to
the serum antibodies we can observe with
the nozzle wash and hie antibodies here
has it seen here that the previous
result was the result already the
seasonal imager virus here I show you
the the same experiment at the protocol
that's the the strain is different that
the this time we used the highly
pathogenic avian influenza A virus h5n1
the we internally administers the
inactivated for variant vaccine and the
corrected sample three weeks after the
vaccination and the result is completely
different from the seasonal strains you
see here in the theorem and the another
was the inter body response is very low
but during the course of the experiment
we measures the antibody secreting a
plasma cells in the TV MC seven days
after the vaccination each vaccination
you see here even the in antibody titer
was low but the after the second
vaccination the number of the plasma
cell inside the vaccinated individuals
is increased in 100% so we decided to
perform the additional vaccination to
those individuals and the result was
here the this is the result neutralizing
tighter after second vaccination but
after the additional vaccination the all
individual responded to the vaccination
here so
this is a summary of the neutralizing
antibody this here the mean geometry
increases 32.9 and the conversion rate
is 88% and the neutralization dreaded
more than 1.8 I want 240 is 88% so the
two naive individuals the third
vaccination is necessary for conclusion
with this part we have examined the
antibody response of internal
administration of the seasonal influenza
virus h3n2 inactivated for very own
vaccine in healthy adults we could
observe high h antibody titers and the
neutralization antibody titers not only
in the serum but also in the nother
washes and administration the
inactivated for very own h5n1 vaccine
twice was not sufficient to induce
neutralizing antibodies in the serum and
now the washed 2 levels found after
seasonal new friends inactivated for
valium vaccination by performing an
additional internal vaccination the
neutralizing antibody titer in the serum
and another was increased dramatically
so serious side effects were not
observed through this clinical
experience so next we further
characterize that neutralizing
antibodies another was so after the vac
Internet o Xfinity like vaccination with
h5n1 and vaccine so another was samples
corrected and concentrated to the
concentrated and the used for the
characterization so who is the main
player in close protection in the
another was and we measured the amount
of the antibodies in another was and the
left upper column showing that 70
percent of antibody another wash is the
IgA and approximately 30% is IgG and
site
the IgM was observed here we separated
these nozzle was is by size using the
gel filtration chromatography in
fractions and as you see here low in the
lower-left figure there are two peaks
the red peak correspond to the monomeric
IgG antibody and the blue peak
corresponds to the IgE antibodies that
we performed the knife page for the each
fractions and the left right the year
showing the the fraction 3231 containing
the monomeric IG antibody and the
fraction set 26 to 30 containing the
dimeric form of iga this is most famous
form of security i j but we can also see
that larger band in the fraction twenty
six twenty three four five and six so to
further analyze we characterized the
weight molecular weight of these
antibodies as you see here the first
plant we could see was a hundred fifty
one killed Abin peak which correspond to
the two heavy chain and two light chain
number one 150 which is there 150 killed
at this is a monomeric form of IgE
antibody and the next to peak we could
observe ways of 406 kiloton speak which
correspond to the four heavy chain and
four light chain at one J chain and one
secretory component which is a fun read
ten kiloton which is the dimeric form of
secretory IgA and next peak 562 and 7.22
correspond to the sixth division by
chain and eight heavy chain lights and
respectively
those are the trimeric form
and the Potomac form of IgA and to
calculate the structure of those
antibodies father
we observed those fractions by the
atomic force microscopy AFM and small
fraction showing the existence of the
monomeric form of IgA which has a 2 F a
B and 1 FC like here that will vary left
fallow and the middle-sized diffraction
showing the containing the dimeric form
of secretory IgA which has a forearms
and the secretory component in the
middle and we also could see the larger
form of IgA which has the eight arms a
further eight a fair B those are so the
fraction containing the tetrameric IgE
antibodies so there there is a larger
form of IgA those one of them are tetra
make IgA shown right here for the next
we wanted to know the functional aspect
of those the polymeric IgE antibodies so
we measured the neutralization against
the wild viruses in that in each
fractions so that we vaccinated with the
Indonesian strain of h5n1 which is
created two point one so right upper
panel showing the old fraction has the
neutralizing ability to create 12.1
Indonesian string of h5n1 but using the
same fractions and measured the
different strains different grade of the
viruses such as Vietnam in strain of HIV
now which is a great one it's a lower
right and the last strain of h5n1 which
is
2.3.4 you see here the monomeric
fraction lacks the neutralization
against the different clade of the
viruses so it means the polymeric IG a
larger sondheimer is very important for
the cross neutralization against the
variant viruses next we further measures
the neutralization ability of each each
form of the and IgE antibodies and this
the right graph showing the minimum of
neutralizing interesting tighter so the
small number means the stronger
neutralization titers
so as you see here the timer is stronger
than monomer and that Tet Rama is
struggling the dimer and polymer
stronger don t trauma neutralization
ability they are showing the strong and
interesting ability so the those are the
characteristics of the iga
and polymeric form I know I mean the
polyclonal situation so we wanted to
know if this characteristic is the same
to the monument monoclonal situation so
we tried to construct the monoclonal
antibodies both the monomeric form and
that Primack forms so we try to product
the recombinant polymeric IgE antibodies
and the characterization of the
neutralization
so the explained to flow is that we
recognize the individuals internally and
collected the PBMC from those individual
seven days after the vaccination and
isolate the plasma cells from as a PBMC
and cloned the antibody gene and produce
recombinant antibody
then character lights that the
government of those in the government
antibodies in order to produce the eye
that the clones that those antibody
genes we selected the antibody producing
cells as the negative direction with a
link a marker and a positive selection
with cd19
and CT 27 and 38 this fraction cells are
collected and the single cell cloned and
the antibody gene was cloned them we
used the protein expression system using
the X P 2 9 3 F cells introducing the
component of the secretory IgA antibody
which it's a heavy chain and light chain
and chain and security component we
managed to found out the method to
produce the polymeric IgE antibodies by
this experience we have cell cultures
them separated those antibodies which
which helps the same variable regions
and measures that minimum concentration
of antibodies for neutralization against
the h1n1 influenza virus obviously here
M Stanford's a monomer and the dimer
theta drama yes surprisingly in even the
monoclonal situation that those have the
same variable region the dimer had the
stronger neutralization compared to the
monomer and the tettemer had the
stronger concent are the stronger
neutralization ability compared to the
timers and c is the crude in containing
all type of the iga devil is here and so
we could obtain the several clones of
the antibodies which neutralized in
front of viruses and we could now
knowledge that make the different
type of daredevil is making the moniker
antibodies such as IgG and IgA those
health that transplant the variable
region to the IgA and also could make
the trimeric IgE antibodies in vitro and
when we compare the neutralization
against the inference of viruses
literally surprising that when we change
from when that in when the atever is in
a GG form you could see the slight new
tradition engage the h-11 here but when
we change the to the edgy a one AG a
monomer even though the variable region
is the same the literal agent against H
1 is increasing and surprisingly when we
change the form to the Tetra mo that
this antibody could neutralize not only
h1n1 but h5n1 influenza viruses like
here and in chrome be monogrammed their
bodies the in when this is the IgG forum
we could see the slight amount of the
new tradition against h1n1 and by
changing it to the IG a monomer form
increased a neutralization and when we
change to the Tetra make form in the
radical increase a new tradition against
h1n1 and we can also observe the
neutralization against the h5n1 like
here
so in conclusion in this system we can
also produce the milligram order of
antibodies in 200 Milotic cell cultures
here ok in conclusions the secretary IgE
antibodies induced by Internet the
influence of action from superstructure
of the dimer trimer and petra mer and
the polymeric IG antibodies so hi year
ability to influence the virus compared
to monomeric or die America antibodies
and mammalian protein expereinces system
helps the research on the inference of a
cause of action and IgE antibodies which
has a potential as a new antibody
medicine well I am missing one line that
the polymeric monoclonal antibodies were
produced and showed higher interest
ability to inflame the viruses and
multimeric security ID antibodies like
these contribute to the prevention of
influenza virus infection thank you very
much a director thank my colleagues
listed here thank you very much for your
attention thank you dr. hasagawa for
your informative presentation but more
importantly the important research
you're doing in Japan amazing we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have questions you'd like
to ask please do so now just click on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen and then click the send
button we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for so let's get started
dr. gawa
the first question from an audience
member is why are the responses to each
three and two and h5n1 so different in
humans oh yeah thank you very much for
the questions in human assuming the
experiment we observed the quite
different responses against the same
component of the vaccine for h1n1 a3 and
a2 and h5n1 because the h3 and two is
the one strain included in the seasonal
influenza virus so we may experience
were exposed to those viruses before
but for h5n1 this is the avian influenza
virus and the most of people are naive
to those viruses so that's code speed at
different responses against the the same
protocol of the vaccinations that which
has an international vaccination hold
that the vaccine that is the main reason
okay thank you so much a researcher
would also like to know how long do h a
specific serum IgG antibodies and
mucosal IgE antibodies last after the
international vaccination oh that is a
very important point that the we
measured the and the follow up the
antibody responses but if our result is
not the experiment in human but we did
experiments in using some macaque monkey
after the internals of vaccination the
serum IgG antibody titer last almost one
year after the vaccination but the
mccordle ID antibodies last
approximately three months after the
vaccination that even though the mucosal
an tiny antibodies that shorter than the
serum IgG antibody response the
antibodies the IgE antibody can induce
very quickly after the exposure of the
virus even after the one year so the the
so even though the the duration time is
shorter but it can be quickly induced by
the exposure to the virus okay thank you
so much
our last question from an audience
member is what is the mechanism by which
the tetrameric IgE antibody has more
broad neutralizing effects against
hetero lodge's influenza virus strains
oh thank you very much that is very
important point
yes yeah they're actually the monomeric
antibodies including IgG and America I
see a can neutralize the virus when the
antibody attached to the neutralizing
active existing in the HMO aq but in
case of the polymeric IgA the size of
not a very itself is quite large so the
antibody attached to the surrounding
area of the news rising epitope also can
neutralize the virus and if there are
the consensus sequence around the news
rising act talk exists so the antibody
which bind it to that area can neutral
also neutralize the even the virus's
hetero 70p
typical viruses wonderful thank you very
much as we close it looks like you have
some nice comments from attendees who I
think may know you and are saying some
compliments about your presentation
that's wonderful do you have anything
you'd like to say as we close for your
audience members I don't want just two
adjectives thank everybody who listened
to my talk thank you very much
wonderful we just want
say thank you again for your wonderful
presentation if there are no more
questions I'd like to also thank lab
roots and get Co part of thermo Fisher
Scientific for making today's
educational webcasts possible additional
questions will be answered and published
on Thermo Fisher Scientific sweb site
you will receive an email notification
when answers are available before we go
I want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through April 2018 you will
receive an email from laborat will be
available for replay please please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed to dot today's live
event thank you again dr. hasagawa
that's all for now joining it we hope to
see everyone again soon enjoy the
conference good bye
thank you bye